we live in very interesting times and as
a young person going into a very
turbulent and fragile economy that is
going to get better it's going to take a
while going into an employment
environment that looks pretty scary it
is easy to lose your moral compass your
decency your sense of civility
and your sense of community very easy
you know things in traffic make you mad
people are getting a little desperate
they might not show their best elements
to you you must never lower yourself to
being a person you don't like there is
no better time than now to have a moral
and civic backbone to have a moral and
civic TrueNorth
this is a tremendous opportunity for you
a young person to be heroic to be
morally upstanding to be helpful
almost Boy Scout like presidential to be
altruistic weakness is what brings
ignorant cheapness racism homophobia
desperation cruelty brutality all these
things that will keep a society chained
to the ground one foot nailed to the
floor it's by being strong in the face
of all of that not lowering yourself to
it that's how you lead that's how you
liberate others and maintain freedom you
don't have to beat your chest you don't
have to wave a flag but to maintain a
high level of decency and it sounds like
I'm a cranky old man like something you
want to rebel against but really think
about what I'm saying I think I'm right
about this when you look at what real
desperation and ignorance looks like
when you have to run from it like
literally run from it
you don't want to be that you want to be
that which leads others out of that and
now more than ever is the time to show
these great qualities to extol these
great qualities and to embody these
great qualities which you have now it's
time to
magnify them personify them and inspire
others with them and there's never been
a time where there needed more than
right now